well we are very excited for our next
guest we're talking about the lovely
Megan Fahey critics call her the
breakout star from the second season of
the hit series The White Lotus Fey he
burst onto the scene back in 2017 she
started as Sutton Brady for five seasons
on the TV series that was called The
Bull type so her new role has fans of
the White Lotus buzzing with a capital B
why she plays Daphne a stay-at-home mom
with some secrets in her marriage to
wealthy businessman Cameron he's a bit
of a jerk here's a clip of Daphne
talking to a new friend Harper played by
Aubry Plaza
I have this trainer in the city
Lawrence he's so handsome he's blonde
hair and nice like big blue eyes
he's really funny too
I spend more time with him than Cameron
sometimes
he's so busy at work
[Music]
such a cutie you wanna see a pic she's
got so many secrets so much more than a
trophy gorgeous wife it is so fun to
watch your character develop and what
she's doing and how she's maneuvering
but what I love is your back story
because you first auditioned for uh the
first season of White Lotus and you
didn't get it yeah I would imagine that
was crushing to you or very
disappointing yeah it was super
disappointing and then you get this
Megan I know it's kind of crazy I still
sort of can't believe that that's how it
ended up unfolding yeah I know because
you think when I don't get it oh oh No
and then this this turns out to be so
much better
yeah I mean I think Mike has this really
amazing ability to just my creator that
great person for the the part and um you
know I was such a fan of the first
season and I watched it and I thought I
couldn't imagine anybody
but that cast doing it you know and I
feel that way about our season as well
so but Mike White the Creator he's
genius because there's all sorts of
twists and turns even with this season
but what do you think about Daphne
because at first I just sort of
dismissed her she's just uh you know a
little bit of a very privileged yeah
elitist she's a trophy wife she's okay
with that but there's so much more she's
quite complicated yeah I mean I think
that's part of the fun you're you're
sort of she's presented in a way that
makes you think that she is you know
quite simple and passive and then I
think watching that sort of unravel in
this in this way is like sort of what
Mike is really good at doing and it's
just it's so fun to play a character
like that it's a wonderful you guessed
it murder mystery what household I have
to say we rewatched the first episode
last night in preparation for the finale
on Sunday and my wife thinks that maybe
your character actually is the killer
care to comment on that well because it
opens in the first episode where we see
a body floating in the world and yeah
and it's not giving anything away you
discover that body yeah uh yeah but what
is the way your character unfolds there
are questions about maybe you're in on
something
well you know I think what's crazy about
the show is it really it could be it
could be any of the guests yes yeah like
there's something about each character
where you're like I could see it being
that person yeah which I think is so fun
I also think it's really fun that people
think it's Daffy yeah okay Tony that was
a good good effort I was reading her
eyes I think it's like you're not gonna
get me you're not gonna get me so you
spent five months in Sicily I like that
um filming this difficult
it's just first world problems yeah very
unfavorable so what was that like though
being there it was amazing I mean we got
there in February it was really cold and
and empty you know a sort of desolate
but even that was great because we kind
of got to just hang out with the locals
and then as the weather warmed up people
started showing up and the energy
shifted and it was like bustling so it
was just it was amazing you know you've
been called the breakout store I love
this this description of you the stealth
scene stealer of White Lotus how do you
feel about the reaction to your
performance and how it's changed from
when you were on the Bold type because
that certainly had a following too to
where you are today and the reaction
that people have to your performance of
Daphne I mean it's very unexpected I
think
um and and quite lovely I mean obviously
anytime anybody says something nice nice
you're like great yeah
um but it's definitely unexpected and
and um I think you know at the end of
the day I'm just so proud to be a part
of a show that has this many incredible
actors that I have respected for so long
before getting to work with them and so
you know know that to me is just like
the chef's kiss I heard that you and
this group of incredible actors were had
some karaoke nights in Sicily oh oh I
bet that was fun you have a go-to song
yeah you know I didn't actually
participate too much because I'm with
you why Megan very smart decision you
know nobody wants somebody who like
actually sings to sing it karaoke it's
like annoying so I kind of uh I took a
back seat but what would be your go-to
song
karaoke night she's saying she's
honestly karaoke she can actually flat
outside I know but I'm just saying
what's your choice of songs I love uh
I'm the only one by Melissa Etheridge I
think that is a karaoke Banger a banger
yeah
are you going to watch the finale on
Sunday with friends you already know
what happened you do already do know
what happened yeah but I am still gonna
watch it because yeah
um I'm still a fan of the show I don't
like watching myself but I'm so excited
to see what everyone else is doing and
the finale is just so epic that I don't
think I can miss it so the finale we
might have a little cast watch party
okay well that'd be fun yeah good
continued success because boy are you
climbing and it's so good to see I
Remember You on The Bold type thank you
so much Megan Fahey the White Lotus
season finale premieres this Sunday on
HBO start catching up now if you haven't
already begun it's a great show thank
you for being here